This is such a beautiful equation. There is so much intuition goes in here.
And there is a few reasons why I love this equation.
First, it says that acceleration is just your normal acceleration due to gravity times some multiplier
and then we can think about, what is this multiplier.
Well, this multiplier depends on the difference of the two masses.
If this masses are identical, well subtracting them will give you zero and you'll have no motion.
Acceleration will be zero exactly like we expected.
If m₂ is bigger than m₁, well this will be positive in the denominator
that means we'll have positive acceleration which we defined as clockwise
Exactly what we expected when m₂ > m₁.
Likewise, if m₁ > m₂, it will be negative which becomes counterclockwise
and finally, in the case where let's say m₂ is >>> m₁.
Let's say m₂ was 1000 kg and m₁ was 1
1000-1, might as well just call it 1000 and ignore the 1.
Likewise,1000+1, who cares about the 1, ignore it. We have the a = g  m₂/m₂, that cancels.
Our acceleration is equal to g 10 m/s². I love that problem. I hope you like it as much as I do.
There is going to be a lot more learning to do on the problem set.
You are not done here, I promise, but I think what you've done today is really amazing. Good work.